vi sarete chiesti come mai io ho
iniziato con il suono della pioggia in
ognuno di noi le sensazioni sono diverse
ovviamente mi piacerebbe condividere con
voi ora un po le mie sensazioni
nella mia infanzia il mio cuore era così
come un cielo bagnato anche in mezzo ai
bambini della mia stessa età mi sentivo
piccola piccolo come quegli occhietti
dietro con le lenti gigantesche che
portavo e sembrava anche che la società
mi vedesse attraverso questa lente
gigantesca
ecco ci vedevo poco punto avevo problemi
di vista e questa cosa mi faceva sentire
in difetto
mi sentivo quasi inutile e la stessa
sensazione mi avevano trasmesso anche un
po tutta la società gli insegnanti
parenti e amici avevano creato in me un
certo senso triste della vita c'era
tuttavia una domanda che da piccola mi
facevo sempre no che cosa farò da grande
e la risposta era quasi ovvia in quel in
quei momenti
ovviamente nulla perché sono quasi cieca
e non potrò fare quasi nulla
tuttavia però una parte di me coltivava
dei sogni così quasi di nascosto come se
fosse un qualcosa di proibito no e devo
dire che è stato davvero questo la forza
che mi ha permesso comunque di andare
avanti nonostante la disabilità
nonostante i pregiudizi
nonostante il cosa potevo non potevo
fare
oggi mi guardo indietro ovviamente si fa
per dire e sono tante le cose che ho
realizzato tanti sogni realizzati a un
lavoro che amo lo sport che è la mia
passione
i miei gatti e tante altre
tanto altro ancora tanti suoni ed
emozioni sempre diversi ma
indimenticabili
ho continuato sempre a pensare no che
cosa mi ha permesso di raggiungere
questi traguardi e di continuare a
coltivare degli altri
ovviamente da tutto questo non pretendo
di avere una risposta
però mi piacerebbe condividere con voi
quello che ho imparato durante questo
cammino per prima cosa qualsiasi
ostacolo e qualsiasi barriera o
qualsiasi problema che noi troviamo nel
nostro cammino
non dobbiamo mai pensare di essere da
soli anche se non vi nascondo che io né
in albania dove sono nata e cresciuta
mi sentivo esattamente così sola poi a
soli 17 anni mi sono imbarcata con i
miei verso l'italia sono arrivata a
milano ed è stato proprio lì che ho
conosciuto delle persone che avevano la
mia stessa disabilità ed è stato proprio
il in quel momento che mi si è aperto un
mondo
voi vi chiederete perché semplicemente
perché ho visto fare il loro cose che
non avrei mai potuto pensare di fare
studiavano lavoravano andavano in giro
da soli
utilizzavano diciamo tutti gli strumenti
tecnologici e tutto in maniera spontanea
serena e felice
e allora mi sono detto beh se ce l'hanno
fatta loro ce la posso fare anch'io e ho
visto finalmente in me un futuro
ovviamente non è facile no anche se hai
un confronto con gli altri
le nostre insicurezze a volte sono più
forti no degli aiuti esterni e io lo so
bene proprio perché ad esempio voi
conoscete tutti o comunque penso quasi
tutti che cos'è questo no
è un bastone per i non vedenti
sapete quanti anni mi ci sono voluti per
prenderlo ma ovviamente ben 25 anni un
giorno
ovviamente c'è sempre un qualcosa che
succede che deve un processo che deve
partire dentro di noi per poter diciamo
affrontare una realtà allora un giorno
mentre tornavo da un corso di computer
mi sono scontrata contro un palo
ovviamente è una situazione che mi
succedeva spesso che può succedermi
ancora oggi ma in quel momento è
scattato qualcosa dentro di me
e allora mi sono detta ok a viola basta
ora è arrivato il momento di affrontare
la realtà è arrivato il momento di non
nascondere il fatto di essere cieca e di
non vergognarmi di questo infatti da lì
ho avuto una certa liberazione no mi
sono sentita molto più rilassata
non è stato facile all'inizio che non vi
nascondo perché le situazioni sia
diciamo commoventi sia quelle un po
comiche erano facciamo un partigiano
della quotidianità
andavo in giro con il bastone e c'era
gente che pensava che avessi perso la
vista a gente che invece pensava chi mi
conosce va un pochino che sapeva che non
ci vedevo pensavano che avessi fatto un
intervento agli occhi in realtà nulla di
tutto ciò avevo fatto semplicemente un
intervento interiore cioè avevo tirato
fuori quello che sono realmente dentro e
avevo voluto diciamo affrontare questa
salita senza vergognarmi ma con orgoglio
vi racconto un aneddoto un po diciamo
divertente o un giorno appunto quando ho
finito di lavorare mentre tornavo a casa
aveva una visita da da fare e allora mi
reco era un dicembre
faceva molto freddo aveva nevicato e
entra in questo studio dove devo fare la
visita e il medico mi dice a è andata a
sciare
no perché no perché la vedo con la
racchetta
dico no in realtà questo è semplicemente
un bastone per per i ciechi per chi non
ci vede e quindi è diciamo era un po un
aneddoto di verduno dei tanti diciamo un
po bucchino che che succedano ancora
oggi
ovviamente questo questo momento per me
è stato un momento di cambiamenti
radicali è stata una crescita continua
che ha dato una svolta totale alla mia
vita perché in quel momento ho iniziato
diciamo ad accettarmi iniziato ad essere
diciamo parte attiva della società è
quello che io penso oggi che la cecità
non è una cosa che mi distingue ma è
semplicemente una mia caratteristica
caratteristiche che comunque tutti noi
abbiamo no nella nella nostra persona la
cecità o la disabilità in generale è
semplicemente una mancanza che viene
sopperita con altre capacità che vanno a
risaltare i nostri valori e quindi in
questo modo continua ancora a crescere
anche la mia diciamo carriera sportiva
la mia carriera professionale
tutte queste cose disegnano ancora oggi
le mie giornate
io ad esempio lavoro in una compagnia
assicurativa che comunque mi da delle
grandi soddisfazioni
mi permetto e anche di poter seguire le
mie passioni anche in maniera diciamo
professionale
questa azienda ha fatto una cosa
magnifica perché ha creato un software
per i non vedenti quindi accessibile ai
non vedenti che interagisce
perfettamente con il
sistema con i software che utilizzano i
normodotati vedenti e tutto questo per
aprire le porte di pari opportunità a
tutti senza distinzione di razza né di
nessun tipo di discriminazione
poi ovviamente non mi fermo qua perché
le mie passioni sono una parte della mia
giornata che mi danno ovviamente gioia
continua allora vi dimostro questo che
cosa vi sembra una balena per cani gatti
non so cosa ho sentito i ricatti no in
realtà questa non è niente di tutto ciò
ma è semplicemente una pallina da
baseball è forata e all'interno ci sono
dei sonagli
questi sono gli permettono a noi
giocatori non vedenti di poter battere
lanciare correre come i normodotati in
un diamante regolare io faccio parte di
una squadra di milano che si chiama
thunder's five milano è il far parte di
una squadra oltre appunto che mi ami ha
permesso oltre alla socializzazione
quindi l'inclusione e l'integrazione
mi ha anche permesso di rinforzare me
stessa di avere diciamo di credere in me
e soprattutto avere fiducia negli altri
oltre a questo è lo sport
comunque da da molto ai disabili perché
ti permette di essere autonoma ti
permette di essere
socievole in giro con il pubblico con le
persone insomma a definisce un po il
carattere della persona cioè non rimane
ghettizzata o comunque chiuso senza
stimoli esterni
ecco poi oltre al baseball ovviamente
continuano le mie passioni perché amo
anche la danza e per me ovviamente la
musica è un qualcosa di significante un
qualcosa di spettacolare e non servono
gli occhi per poter ballare e la musica
a me fa sentire libera leggera con una
foglia presidente che fluttua nel vento
ma a tutti noi la musica in realtà ci
coccola e nello stesso tempo ci dà
energia per ricaricarci ecco poi
passiamo a un altro sport
direte ma quanti sport pratiche in
realtà io amo lo sport e questo era uno
dei miei sogni che coltivavo da piccola
non poter praticare gli sport e ne
faccio ne ho fatti vi diversi però
quelli più importanti sono esattamente
questi vi dimostro
anche questo questo è una corda che io
utilizzo per correre in una parte lo
tengo io e dall'altra parte la tiene la
persona che mi accompagna durante la
corsa
ovviamente voi direte facile no basta
seguire la persona che ti sta guidando
il gioco è fatto
per poter correre insieme bisogna che ci
sia molto feeling che si entri in
sinergia e bisogna essere molto
sincronizzati bisogna diventare
prefiniti una cosa unica e per fare
tutto questo è importante ovviamente
l'affiatamento è importante lavorare
molto e spesso peralta atleti
normodotati c
ci vedono come diciamo atleti di ii
livello in realtà non è assolutamente
così perché anche per noi che
pratichiamo lo sport a livello
agonistico l'atletica livello agonistica
diciamola come il livello di
competizione e il medesimo quindi atleti
normodotati atleti paralimpici
siamo tutti diciamo sulla stessa linea
di partenza ecco ovviamente tutto questo
quello che lo rende magico sono le
emozioni e la determinazione è la lavori
ovviamente di di continuare a non
arrendersi mai
ma di cercare di ovviamente superare
ogni nostro limite ea volte anche quando
io le gare o quando sono davanti a delle
persone a parlare a un pubblico come voi
la gente pensa che per noi sia più
facile no poter parlare poterci diciamo
poter manifestare le nostre attività in
realtà perché pensano che noi non non
percepiamo non vediamo chi ci sta
guardando chi ci sta osservando
in realtà non è così perché anche noi io
stessa sento diciamo il tifo delle
persone che mi sostiene sento la gioia
di chi mi fa i complimenti dopo una
vittoria
sento anche e soprattutto la pacca sulla
spalla delle persone che mi sostengono
dopo una sconfitta perché ovviamente c'è
anche quello nelle competizioni o anche
nella vita stessa
ma importante è non arrendersi mai e
continuare a correre a proposito di
emozioni no ci state se proviamo a fare
un piccolo esperimento insieme
ok allora proviamo a chiudere gli occhi
tutti mi raccomando chiudete di tutti
anche voi che ci state guardando da
internet ad esempio e cercate di non
barare perché vi vedo
allora proviamo in silenzio ad ascoltare
un po i nostri respiri ascoltiamo un po
il rumore delle persone che abbiamo
intorno a noi sentiamo ricordiamo i
profumi del pranzo che abbiamo condiviso
insieme e sentite anche la mia voce
io sento la voce stanca ma carica di un
centinaio di persone che ha vissuto una
giornata intensa e piena di emozioni
sento anche in realtà lo smarrimento
vostro per avervi privato per un istante
dalla vista ma proviamo a cambiare
prospettiva proviamo a non focalizzarsi
solo sul senso della vista perché il
nostro corpo ha tantissimi sensi che ci
possono far vedere le cose anche sotto
un altro punto di vista anche sotto un
altro aspetto
cominciamo a guardare oltre
diciamo a quello che è il visivo ok ora
aprite pure gli occhi la vita
cio ci propone ovviamente delle sfide
davanti a noi ma se accettiamo queste
sfide che ci vengono poste davanti se ci
confrontiamo con altri che hanno vissuto
le nostre stesse cose e se prendiamo un
ostacolo come un insegnamento
allora io credo che possiamo vedere un
futuro migliore grazie